I saw a weakness in you on your latest
podcast you seem to overlook the fact
that some infant children were raised in
undisciplined environments with
undisciplined parents they grow up
having modeled these undisciplined
examples I hate the fact that I have
gross undisciplined behavior solving
this is a major priority in my life
you have zero idea of what it of what
this experience is like for me
you seem blind to this struggle like a
father who would ignore their child
struggle and offer only the words mana
so this is a good question and I I see
where this guys coming from for sure and
I know that it can be very very
frustrating to try and become
disciplined and I apologize that I
haven't talked about the fact of what to
do if you come from an undisciplined
family or you have undisciplined parents
I haven't really talked about what to do
in that situation but there's a reason
that I haven't talked about that before
and that is because you don't get
discipline from your parents you don't
get discipline from your parents from
your grandparents from your older
brothers and sisters you don't get
discipline from an external source you
have to get it from you
that's what self-discipline is you get
it from yourself you get it from you so
there's people from every possible
background from no parents to crazy
parents to you no drug-addicted parents
to super squared away parents and
everywhere in between on that spectrum
that are completely disciplined people
more disciplined than anyone I know it
doesn't come from your parents you don't
inherit it and there's another piece
here
it's called ownership right it's called
ownership and if you're if you want to
blame other people for the problem and
say this all the time if you don't take
ownership of the problem the problems
don't get solved so if you blame your
parents for not having raised you in a
disciplined environment you're not gonna
solve that problem you're looking at
your parents saying if you would have
done a better job being more disciplined
for me I would be more discipline now so
that means that means you can't do
anything the fact the matter is it's
wrong you actually can do something and
it doesn't matter what do how your
parents raised you and brought you up
you can have the discipline you need to
decide to do it so as long as you're
blaming other people I mean if you blame
me from not discussing it you blame me
for having zero idea what that
experience is like you blame your
parents for not raising you this way as
long as you're blaming other people as
long as you're counting on other people
to give you discipline as long as you do
that you will not have it so again I I'm
sorry I should have made that I should
make that more clearly I'm trying to
make it more clearly now and like my
parents my parents are are good people
they had successful careers as as
educators in public schools and my mom
eventually became went into school
administration and my dad taught in high
school for 30-something years and they
were good hard-working people and but
I'll tell you they were no they were no
extraordinary preachers of discipline
and I'll tell you I act I I never
remember either one of them ever using
the term or referring to discipline in
any way you know and actually both my
parents worked they both worked a lot
my dad was coaching sports and we're
doing after school stuff my mom's same
things like we were on our own a bunch
but my parents were gone in the morning
we got ourselves to school when we got
home in afternoon they weren't home you
know so it wasn't like they were setting
up this rigid disciplined manner for me
right and
and you can see this with families many
many different families there's families
that have kids that the parents are very
disciplined and the kids are wild
mm-hm sometimes that problematically so
right kids that come from really good
families but they get addicted to drugs
lack of discipline kids that come from
really good families but they they spin
out of control and go in the wrong
direction and there's also the opposite
which is hey the parents weren't around
or the parents were abusive or the
parents were drug addicts and and all
the cousins the kid the kid comes out of
that and is squared away is awesome and
we saw that all the time the SEAL Teams
and I've said that before on this
program doesn't matter it doesn't matter
where your background is is what you
decide to do yeah
and I'll tell you another thing it's not
even from the military like the military
requires discipline obviously but
there's plenty of people in the military
that don't have it right and and many
poor many people lose their discipline
when they leave the mulch because not
being imposed on them anymore so I mean
just go look around I mean being in the
military does not make you a disciplined
person being from a discipline family
does not make you a discipline person
being in a discipline group does not
make you a discipline person what makes
you a discipline person is choosing to
be disciplined so yeah I I and also as
far as telling people to man up which
you know when someone says how do I get
up early every day I say get up early
every day how do I stop eating sugar
stop eating sugar look that's the
definition of mana but obvious it's not
just men that need discipline in their
life I don't think I use that term but
what I do tell people is to get after it
that's what I tell people to get after
it you know I tell people to do the
things that they know they're supposed
to do right there's things that you know
you're supposed to do as a human being
things that you know are going to
improve your life do those things
there's things that you know are gonna
make you a worse person and make your
life worse don't do those things
do the things that are making you weaker
start doing the things that are gonna
make you stronger and smarter and faster
and healthier and gonna make you a
better human being and I'll say the same
thing to this guy you want to be more
disciplined get after it
that's it get up early do some kind of
workout eat good foods clean your room
make a list of things that you're
supposed to do in your life and then
wake up in the morning and do those
things that you put on the list
that's what discipline is and know it is
not easy but you're not gonna get it
from anyone else but you and it's worth
it and it is the thing that is going to
bring you freedom that's the key word
right there when he said it's worth it
you know what I think this is what I
think I think like in an environment as
like how he put it an undisciplined
environment I mean or something like
that where he grew up in an
undisciplined environment I don't
obviously that's a very vague expression
right undisciplined infirm yeah that got
meaning that could mean a lot of yeah a
lot of different things so a lot of
times like when you're brought up in a
certain environment basically you're
kind of taught or or not taught like
like the value of certain things so if
you use like I don't know working out or
whatever right so I'm gonna use myself
as an example my dad is an athlete you
know not a superior athlete but he was
you know he knew like working out was a
part of life and stuff like that and you
know in elementary school we're doing
sports and stuff like that you know some
people they don't do that at all so and
when they grow up into adulthood the
some people straight up have never
worked out before never been in the gym
and you know so growing up there they
were never taught the value of what work
you know does for you they never taught
so they can't appreciate it they just
simply don't know the value sure they
see people with you know you know
they're in shape where they can do these
things and they're very functional
whatever they see that of course but
they don't have that value they don't
feel that value they just never learned
so it can come off as like this thing
for other people you know like oh that's
what other people do kind of thing so
they don't understand the value so back
to the point in their mind this weird
the connection is not made that it's
worth it
because they don't know the value of it
really but if you do know the value of
it and then you can decide okay is this
worth it is it worth it to wake up every
day and in quote-unquote get after it
for this particular goal or this
particular set of goals so that's what
it is and I think sure the undisciplined
environment can maybe provide that but I
think you're right I think that once
you're like oh yeah that's worth it yeah
you know how people they'll find reasons
when it's worth the even though they've
never experienced like you know like a
person who has a heart attack or
something is like and they have kids
young kids are some they have a heart
attack life maybe never worked out ever
in their life they have a heart attack
they almost died they're like guess what
I'm working out every single day I'm a
vegetarian now you know like doing major
major changes that they've never even
thought about making and they'll do it
because they decided it's worth it and
they'll be disciplined they'll find that
discipline real quick no matter how
they're trained as you know their
environment in there because now I see
that it's gonna be worth it that's it
yeah and if if it's not worth it to you
and that I think is what you develop the
value of work you know the value of you
develop you can develop that from
anywhere that's one of that's but
essentially that has really developed
that from any any you can develop that
from from anywhere yeah yeah you can get
it from a parent you can get it from
yeah exactly right exactly right but the
discipline itself just like I said
that's gonna come from you your parents
can teach it but guess who has to you
still you it's still you and you can go
to the military to specifically learn
discipline when you leave it's on you
who's it yeah exactly right and just
like I said like yeah I know people who
are done with the military and are glad
they're done with that right they're
glad with this waking up early they're
they're a baby they were six months
they're out of shape they're not doing
anything productive it's it's horrible
to see you know but it happens happens
with the military it happens with
anything yeah when kids get out of high
school sports you know and all of a
sudden they don't want enough to do that
I don't have to listen to coach yeah
yeah crazy - don't listen to coach
listen to yourself yourself yeah
determine whether or not it's worth it
and I'm telling you that you don't need
to determine I'm telling you it's worth
it oh yeah I'm telling you it is working
and you know what you actually know it's
worth it that's why you're asking this
question you know it's worth it you know
it's worth it to have discipline but you
think there's an easier way you think
that it's something that people have you
think that when Jacko's alarm clock goes
off it's like oh just like my father
taught me
I rise and I shine you know like no I
it's like the pillow feels soft and
comfortable and the alarm clock is
banging on my head and I don't like it
you know what I know it's worth it to
get up and get after it I know it's
worth it and you know it's worth it
here's the thing though we all know it's
worth it is it in a way you're right but
like really though really I'm gonna be
open and honest with you I don't think
that the people know it's worth it I
think they know it's worth it like the
kind on paper they have a multiple
choice question is it worth it yes or no
they'll be like yes obviously I know
working out is worth it but here's the
thing
I don't if you don't know if you don't
like like having good credit for example
so I never got taught like why really my
mom said yeah you should have good
credit that's it that's the limit to my
education on credit right so of course I
blow it because they get you know I fall
for literally all the tricks it's
self-inflicted and otherwise credit gets
jammed up so I don't know I don't know
the value I don't know I have never
experienced the benefits of having good
girl you of good credit so it really
didn't mean much to me really my credit
was like junk and I didn't care until I
got denied for something that I cared
you know but just like if you're never
into working out until you're in a
specific situation what show but but but
like this guy that's asking this
question and glad he's asking a question
I'm I'm not I'm trying I'm not trying to
come off all hard but he realizes he
realizes the value of discipline cuz
he's saying that he wants it right he
knows that it's gonna make his life
better yeah and and that's why I think
he's got
and jammed up in whatever way we don't
know cuz I don't know maybe he's gotten
unhealthy maybe he's you know who knows
maybe he's gotten his finances jammed up
whatever the case may be
he knows that discipline is better for
them him he knows that he does know this
isn't a guy that doesn't know yet cuz
sure there's people that don't you know
when you're 16 years old you don't know
the value of discipline you don't know
that the what your the way you're acting
right now is gonna affect you in five
years you don't know you can set
yourself your whole life up to be pretty
awesome you know you don't know that yet
you're just like worried about where
you're going on a Friday night right
yeah so this guy knows and he wants it
and he's looking for where he can find
it and where he can find it is in the
mirror yeah that's where it is you know
so do it brother good luck get on the
path and stay on the path
yeah and that's gonna be beneficial when
you do that I've harshly maintaining
that like not knowing that value is a
big is a big thing it's kind of like
okay so back to my credit thing I there
is a point at the end where okay so you
know like I don't know 10 years ago or
whatever I repaired my credit my credit
was repaired I thought I went through it
was painstaking not fun stuff no but I
did it got my credit repaired and now I
know the value because as an adult I'm
functioning it's useful now you know so
now I know the value of having good
credit because I've been through all the
things that having good credit
brings you through you know now I'm
thinking I'll never go back to bedrock
right never it's right every single day
I'm telling you that I agree with what
you're saying yeah I agree with her
you're saying I'm saying that this guy
knows the value and that's why he wants
it yeah it's like when you freight
realize that you got denied for
something and you were like oh oh credit
has value I understand that something
happened in his life where he said
discipline has value I know that now
yeah but you did credit repair and in
what you said was okay I need to go out
and repair my credit you didn't say hey
you know what my mom didn't tell me
about bad credit and now I have bad
credit yeah yeah so now now what am I
supposed to do you know who repaired
your credit who repaired your credit
well it was a combination of my wife and
I but
but who repaired your credit yeah we'd
yes yeah you took responsibility for it
and said okay I'm gonna get my credit
card she's smarter than you yes she was
like hey I will I will help this but it
was you that said okay I got to get this
fixed mm-hmm and you got help but you
knew to reach out for help but you're
the one that ultimately is responsible
for it yeah you're right about that like
I didn't like I didn't blame my parents
and then continue having that good right
no right like they said no I gotta get
Val this is this thing has credit has
value I need to fix it yeah and you
fixed it you know regardless where it
came from
regardless so oh you know oh you don't
know how to work out cool then you go
hire a personal trainer because you know
it's gonna it's the right thing to do
you don't even oh you don't know how to
repair your finances cool go get a
counselor that's gonna help you repair
your finances oh you're addicted to
drugs or alcohol okay I'm gonna go find
a counselor or join a group so I can get
through that thing yeah no one's gonna
hold your hand and bring you into the
any of those situations you got to do it
yourself you got the discipline to make
it happen